hello everyone
today we're going to be working through
goody bag 5 which is on electronic
materials
namely semiconductors in order to follow
along you'll need a multimeter
a pair of alligator clips some large
leds i'll be using red
white blue and green and some regular
size leds i'll be using red
blue and purple our main objectives
today are to identify differently
colored leds by radiating them with
light across the visible light spectrum
and in the process to explore the
relationship between the band gap of a
semiconductor and its critical
absorption wavelength
as we work through the goody bag i'd
like you to think about how the size of
the band gap of material
may influence which wavelengths of light
it can absorb let's get started
first connect your black or negative
lead to the 10 amp port on the
multimeter and then your red
or positive lead to the voltage ohm
milliamp port
then connect the probe end of each
respective lead to one end of an
alligator clip
after you do this you should still have
two free ends of the alligator clips
grab one of your small leds and connect
the free end of the alligator clip
connected to the red lead probe to the
positive end of the led
this is the longer leg of the led and
then connect the other free end that's
connected to the black lead probe to the
negative end of the led that's the short
leg of the led
then turn on your multimeter and set the
dial to 2000
milli dc volts this is the order of
magnitude of voltage
we'll measure across our small leds when
we irradiate them with light from the
larger leds
finally make sure to keep track of which
small led you're testing
so that you know which led to refer to
when we start comparing data between
small leds
so now we have our small led hooked up
to our multimeter
and now we're going to shine each one of
our large leds onto the small led and
record whether or not we have some
non-zero voltage reading
if the large led has enough energy to
excite electrons across the band gap
of the small led we should see some
non-zero voltage across the small led
so first i'm going to try and shine this
blue light
onto my small led and i'm going to look
at the multimeter and try to see if
there's some voltage dropped
okay as you can see our voltmeter is now
measuring
some non-zero value which means that
this blue light has enough energy to
excite electrons across
its band gap after you've done this
repeat this for the other
large leds and then repeat the entire
experiment for the other two small leds
this should generate a set of 12 data
points and using our knowledge of band
gaps and wavelength absorption as well
as the data that you've acquired
we're going to determine which small led
is what color
so after running through your
experiments you should have some chart
that looks like mine
where i have my small leds going down
the side here and the large leds going
across
so each square represents a time when a
small led was irradiated by
a large led and a check represents when
a non-zero voltage was
measured across the multimeter and an x
represents when
there was a zero or very low voltage
reading
across the led okay so in order to
dig into what this means it's important
to understand the bounds
of the visible light spectrum in terms
of energy and wavelength
so if you remember the visible light
spectrum known uh
wonderfully by the acronym origin
where you have red on one end and you
have violet on the other end
we know that red corresponds to around
700 nanometers in wavelength and we know
that violet or purple
corresponds to around 420 nanometers
of wavelength and if we think back to
the relationship between the energy of
light
and its wavelength we know that the
formula is e
it is hc over lambda so
as the wavelength of light decreases
the energy of light increases so going
across as we go from
red green blue and white we have
increasing energy because we have
decreasing wavelength
and just as a reminder white is a
composite of
red blue and green so it has all three
of these combined
in so now let's start to identify which
led is what color so if you look at
small led1
it was irradiated by red green blue and
white light
and there was a voltage drop across the
led for all
that means that at the very least red
had enough
energy to excite electrons across the
band gap of that small led
because that's the case and we know that
we're dealing with leds which emit light
the visible light spectrum
we know that this small led then must be
red so if we look at small led 2
we can see that both red and green light
did not have enough energy
to excite electrons across the band gap
the second led but
when we shine blue light onto the led we
got a non-zero voltage drop
and the same thing when we shine white
light which also has blue light in it
because like i said in the beginning we
knew that our small leds were
red blue and purple and we've already
found a red led
that means that this led must be
the blue so finally if we look at small
led number three we can see that
red green blue and white light did not
have
sufficient energy to cause some voltage
drop across the led
if we look back to roy g biv and we
think about the energy
of of red to blue that means that they
didn't have enough energy
to excite anything after it and that
means
that our final led must be violet or
purple
[Applause]
so by shining light across the visible
light spectrum onto our small leds we're
able to identify
which one of our small leds are what
color so right here i have small led1
hooked up to the multimeter and we
determined it was red
and so we can check that by just turning
on the led
so as you can see this led is shining
red which means it's the red led
and we're able to confirm that by using
our data as well you can check that the
other two leds are the colors that we
determined by doing the same thing
so today we looked at a direct
application of semiconductors in leds
we looked at the relationship between
the band gap of an led semiconductor
and the range of light that can absorb
across its band gap
we found that for semiconductors there
are some critical absorption wavelengths
some maximum
wavelength below which the led will
absorb
all other wavelengths of light